going to show you the number one remedy
for palpitations it's a very easy quick
remedy I had palpitations really bad at
one time I thought it was a heart
problem it wasn't I'll explain that but
what is a palpitation it's an irregular
eurythmic beet that can come and go and
before I get into the most common one I
want to cover all of the reasons why you
might have
palpitations one is stress stress
affects the cardiovascular system it
affects the electrolytes behind the
cardiovascular system and so there is
such a thing as stress-induced
palpitations number two caffeine too
much caffeine can do it as well caffeine
is a stimulant and it can affect the
heart I personally only have one cup of
coffee in the morning that's it of
course in the past in college I used to
drink pots of coffee right but I tell
you I am much healthier now than when I
was in college you know I just have to
say one little thing about that you want
to learn from the mistakes of others of
course I didn't really do that at the
time I had to go through a lot of pain
and suffering before I figured it out
don't wait until you have a health
problem before you do something about it
all right number three wine that's right
wine can create palpitations now it
could be from the alcohol or it could be
from the salt fights which you might be
sensitive to all right number four is
gluten that's the protein in Grain
certain grains in fact it's the only
protein that can't be digested by our
bodies so it does affect our guts and
also whatever goes on in your gut can
affect
your brain and even the heart you have
this close proximity of your digestive
organs to the heart and the liver it's
all kind of you know tightly um jammed
into your chest area
and especially when you get a fatty
liver things kind of expand in there and
then it presses on certain things so you
can even have a congested gallbladder
that can affect the heart as well so if
you have sludge down the bile ducts
that's connected from your liver to your
gallbladder that can create palpitations
as well and then actually just food
allergies what happens when you have a
food allergy is you get this little
spike in your pulse rate right so you do
have this connection and this is kind of
in the category of what they call
gastrocardiac syndrome
gastro digestion cardiac heart syndrome
so basically you eat certain things that
disagree with certain things and then
you get symptoms not just palpitations
you can get heartburn
gas bloating and even chest pain so of
course the first thing I would do if I
had palpitations now is kind of scan
through to make sure what I'm eating is
not creating problems now also I want to
put this on your radar certain
medications especially to medications
that decongest your sinuses antibiotics
anti-fungals thyroid medications
antipsychotic medications
antidepressants all can affect the heart
and create palpitations I mean that's
kind of like the elephant in the room if
you're taking these medications
you have no idea what side effects could
be coming from those the next Point
number seven is hyperthyroidism okay
this is not as common but if you're
hyperthyroid your thyroid is working too
fast that can definitely create heart
palpitations and even severe arrhythmias
all right number eight electromagnetic
fields you can pick it up with a little
tri-filled electromagnetic field tester
I went through my room my computer I
went through the entire house to find
out where these electromagnetic fields
were coming from in strong amounts and I
was shocked to find out in the back of
my bed my headboard
um it was like I was literally like
eight feet extended out from my
headboard
there was this very strong
electromagnetic field okay I was being
bathed in this electromagnetic field and
guess what your heart is electrical so
what happened was
I had the electrician take down the
walls and find all sorts of these cross
wires whoever um did the electrical did
not know what they were doing they were
probably drunk when they did it because
they messed everything up when they
fixed those wires
wow my sleep improved greatly I woke up
feeling more refreshed and the
palpitations went away so you can check
your computer even like your battery
backup or some of the cables and you'll
be shocked to find out how much of this
um electromagnetic field is being
generated but there's all sorts of
things you can do to just reposition
things and then number nine over
exercise which can create problems with
the heart especially if you're not
recovering or sleeping so I've known
patients and things that just over
trained and they had palpitations and
all we did is make some adjustments with
that and went away
okay number 10 this is the most common
one right here it is a magnesium
deficiency magnesium is probably the
most common deficiency
uh when someone gets arrhythmias
especially palpitations and then I would
say potassium would be the next one 66
of the population is deficient in
magnesium probably because most of the
Magnesium that we get come from plants
and salads and things like that and an
average person
in the world consumed only like 1.5 cups
of vegetable per day you would need
basically a right around 7 to 10 cups of
salad or if you're doing just vegetables
maybe four to five cups but the point is
that your problem could be that you're
just not getting enough from the diet
magnesium is at the heart of chlorophyll
which actually is the green stuff in the
plants
chlorophyll mimics your blood with one
tiny change as far as the chemistry goes
blood has iron which is red chlorophyll
has magnesium which is green not to
mention when you refine foods and eat
refined sugars you are consuming
something without hardly any magnesium
and if you get a blood test and it shows
normal magnesium realize that the
majority of magnesium like
99.8 percent of all the Magnesium is
inside the cell not on your outside in
the blood it's inside the cell so unless
you do an intracellular magnesium test
you're not going to find a lot of
medications deplete magnesium stress
depletes magnesium so you have a couple
choices I think the best thing to do is
to increase more salads
um seven to ten cups what is one cup
just think about a like a small handful
of salad that's one cup now you can also
use a supplement I recommend magnesium
glycinate but the point is magnesium is
a really common electrolyte and if you
do the vegetables you'll basically kill
two birds with one stone you'll get
potassium and magnesium and just realize
it does take some time to build up to
actually fulfill this deficiency if you
have one it could take weeks or even
some months it doesn't always happen
overnight but I think this is a very
important topic especially if you are
living with palpitations now since we're
on this topic of digestion affecting the
heart I think you should really get more
information about this gallbladder
connection as well and for that I put
this video up right here